i've written a film that's been honored  here about a boy who watched movies in a  north belfast working-class household  including seeing the oscar ceremony  beamed to the north of ireland and that  same story has taken me back to the real  place but this time i'm seeing it from  the stage not from my front room on  television so  that is an idea to really get your head  down enjoy everything enjoy this moment  enjoy watching movies which i did part  of what happened in belfast is you got a  chance to put your love for the movies  and  your love for the place that you came  from where you started watching movies  on the screen you put your heart there  you put your instinct there you wrote it  because you had to so i'd say to my  younger self just try and do all the  things you need to do although all the  stories you have to tell try and tell  them because they're the best ones